cuando estaba en la universidad la nave
se aproximó a mí y hablaron de ayudar a
las mujeres en crisis y su compromiso de
mantener el aborto seguro legal y escaso
yo estaba convencida de ser voluntaria y
de ofrecer y me ofrecieron un trabajo
como asistente médica antes de mi
promoción a la directora de la clínica
realmente creí que estaba ayudando a las
mujeres pero las cosas cambiaron
drásticamente en el año 2009 en abril me
dieron el premio de empleada del año y
me llevaron a su gala donde presentaron
el mar
el premio margaret sanger en nombre de
su fundadora era una racista que pensaba
en la agencia y pensaba que había que
erradicar las poblaciones minoritarias
hoy cerca del 80% de las instalaciones
de planta están estratégicamente
ubicadas en barrios de minorías y cada
año se celebra sus raíces racistas
presentando el premio margaret sanger en
agosto mi supervisor me dio una nueva
cuota que cumplir una cuota de abortos
se suponía que debía duplicar la
cantidad de abortos del año anterior
cuando me di cuenta de que iba en contra
de lo que me han dicho que me dijeron
que las abortos es la manera como
ganamos dinero pero el punto de
inflexión cambió cuando un médico me
llevó a asistir 11 ultrasonido
para un aborto nada me preparó para lo
que pude ver en esa pantalla y una bebé
luchando de manera desesperada para
alejarse de la succión y nunca me
olvidaré de lo que me dijo el doctor
después
lo último que vi fue su espina dorsal
moviéndose antes de antes sucumbir a la
fuerza de la succión
el 6 de octubre
es por eso que ahora soy una activista
pro-vida
ahora dirijo una organización sin ánimo
de lucro que ha ayudado a cerca de 600
trabajadores fuera de su industria
la mayoría de las personas que se
consideran prohibidas
el aborto es algo abstracto ni siquiera
pueden concebir la barbarie son los
productos de lo que ocurre ahí donde los
cuerpos de los niños
ya se hacían bromas diciendo que eran
los cuartos de la sal
[Música]
como se ve sea que huele saben que el
aborto incluso tiene un olor si decido
la perpetradora de estos actos con bebés
y con las mujeres y ahora apoyo a camps
porque él ha hecho mucho más por los
bebés no nacidos que ningún otro
presidente durante su primer mes
prohibió el financiamiento para los
grupos que promovían el aborto y ese
mismo año cambió una regla de la era de
obama que permite a los subsidios para
el aborto
a jueces incluyendo dos jueces de la
corte suprema y anunció una nueva regla
protegiendo los derechos de los
trabajadores de salud que se oponen al
aborto muchos de los cuales con los que
trabajo ahora todos los días la vida es
un punto central de lo que somos como
estadounidenses y esta elección es una
elección entre dos activistas activistas
anti vida y el presidente más pro vida
que hayamos tenido y eso es algo que
debería convencerlos y llevarlos a la
acción
vayan puerta a puerta xiamen hablen con
sus vecinos y con sus amigos y voten el
3 de noviembre y tomen acción que lleve
a trump a la reelección para proteger a
los más vulnerables a aquellos que no
han nacido aún